من دمشق ضم الينا المتحدث باسم اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في سوريا عدنان حزم
سيد عدنان مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه ما
هو تقييمكم اولا في الصليب الاحمر لحجم
الدمار الذي خلفه هذا الزلزال في المناطق
السوريه المنكوبه
اعتقد معكم وفي تقريركم او ماذا تتناوله
القنوات من صور
لحجم هذا
الزلزال واثاره الكارثيه قد يكون هو فقط
جزء بسيط من الواقع الماساوي الكارثي الذي
خلفه خلفه هذا
الزلزال طبعا نحن في اللجنه الدوليه
الصليب الاحمر ومنذ الساعه الاولى
متواصلين مع شريكنا الهلال الاحمر العربي
السوري في تقديم العون الانساني والاغاثه
والطب
خلال هذه حتى هذه اللحظه هناك تنسيق مع
شركائنا بالعمل الانساني في سوريا لتقديم
المزيد وكذلك
للتخفيف من معاناه
المتضررين من هذه الكارثه التي اضافت الى
وجعل السوريين المنا اضافيا كونه لسوريا
كما تعرف
عانه وتعاني حتى اللحظه من من اثار صراع
لمده 12 عام
اثر كثيرا على جوانب الحيه بشكل عام حتى
هذه اللحظه هناك ارقام مرعبه عندما تتكلم
اليوم عن 15 مليون سوري بحاجه لمساعدات
عندما تتكلم ان 50% من المنشات الصحيه لا
تعمل هذه الارقام هو غيرها من الارقام
التي تسمعونها او هذه المشاهد الذي
تعرضونها تعكس الواقع الماساوي والكارثه
في سوريا تحياتي الزلزال ليضيف اوجاعا
وماساه اخرى للشعب
اتاثر بشكل كبير في مختلف حياته اليوميه
في ظل هذه الظروف كيف تسير عمليات الانقاذ
والمساعده للمنكوبي
طبعا على مدار الساعه هناك فرق الهلال
الاحمر العربي السوري وكذلك
غيري من الدفاع المدني وغيرهم ليقومون
بانتشال الجثث من تحت الانقاذ وانقاذ من
يمكن انقاذهم من تحت الركام الى جانب ان
هناك مراكز وتم انشاء في المناطق المنكوبه
نحن دورنا باللهجه الدولي الاحمر قمنا
بالتزويد بعض المستشفيات بالمواد الجراحيه
وكذلك المواد الاغاثيه والغذائيه لتلك
المراكز الايوائيه
ماذا تحتاج الان هذه المناطق يعني طبيعه
هذه المساعدات التي تحتاجها
وخاصه هناك الكثير من الدول التي اعلنت عن
حزم من المساعدات سترسلها الى تركيا
وسوريا كيف سيتم
طبعا مثل هذه المبادره التي قمت بها
الدول في تقديم العون العاجل لسوريا هي
هي قد تخفف من المعاناه ونتمنى ان تتواصل
كذلك المزيد من من الدعم وخاصه في مجال
رفع الانقاب
وايجاد وايجاد
وايجاد حلول او تدخلات انسانيه تخفف من
المعاناه ليس فقط في هذه الكارثه ولكن
نتكلم عن الماسه الماساه الوضع السوري
بشكل عام
هل هناك مساعدات يعني الدوليه من اي طرف
كان وصلت الان او هل هناك اي اتصالات تجري
مع ايات اي منظمات ايضا اخرى الدوله دوليه
مستعده لتقديم اي نوع من المساعده
طبعا اي جهد انساني في مثل هذه الحالات هو
مرحب ونحن في اللجنه بالاحمر وقبل هذه
الكارثه
ندعو مازلنا ندعو الى ان يكون هناك المزيد
من الانتباه واعطاء سوريا لملفها الانساني
المزيد من الدعم في مختلف المجالات كما
قلت لك هناك تداعيات خلفتها الازمه في
المجال الخدمي في المجال الاقتصادي في
المجال الصحي في جميع المجالات نتمنى ان
يكون هذا ان يكون هذا التداعي الانسانيه
والتحشيد الانساني من الدول ان يستمر حتى
بعد معالجه هذه الكارثه او ان يكون هناك
وصول المساعدات الى سوريا الان السيد
عدنان
طبعا في بالمجمل في العمل الانساني او
الاغاثه هناك عوائق مختلفه سواء كانت على
الجانب الامني او كذلك طبيعه المناطق
وخاصه عندما يكون هناك سواء كان هناك
زلازل او فيضانات هناك مع ذلك كمنظمه
انسانيه نعمل على ايجاد حلول في اصابه تلك
المساعدات ولكن ندعو الان الى ان يكون
هناك تحشيد حقيقي
لمعالجه تداعيات هذا الزلزال واثره
السلبيه والكارثيه على المناطق التي تاثرت
في سوريا وان يكون هناك استجابه مستدامه
للحاله الانسانيه في سوريا